David last time we were talking about
the sinful woman in Luke seven and there
were some other interesting things that
happen in Luke eight and nine and we
just don't have enough time to go over
all of them now we're getting into a
section of the gospel where Luke begins
to tell the story of Jesus and his his
activity of disciple is the best way to
describe it and what's going on with all
of these stories of Jesus and there are
more stories in Luke than there are on
the other guys there are these decipher
its I think I think the fact that that
we're moving from Luke to acts as a way
of remembering that this is not just
about Jesus ministry this is about Jesus
ministry and the founding of the church
if there's a gospel where Jesus founds
the community as well as calling
disciples this is it so what we begin to
see in the first part of chapter 10 and
elsewhere in Luke's Gospel is Jesus
empowering those who will be his
followers and then in the book of Acts
we see how those empowered apostles
actually begin to live out his mission
to do some other things he's done cast
out demons work miracles proclaim the
gospel he's concerned for continuities
in a way that I think he's not so
concerned about him in Matthew and Mark
for sure now one of the people who
features prominently at this point is
Peter yes and how does Luke sporter to
Peter contrast with that that we get to
say in Matthew my reading and I'd love
to hear your take on this because this
may be a Baptist versus Catholic thing
my reading on Peter in Luke's Gospel is
that he is representative of the
community rather than taking on
particular authority of his own that
that when he confesses who Jesus is that
then Jesus says to all the disciples
what that confesses his own massage said
to all the disciples and the Peters not
singled out as being the rotten which
the Turkish built churches built but
becomes a paradigmatic confessor of the
faith as you'll be a paradigmatic
apostle in acts hugely important but
important as an example of the larger
reality rather than is a particular
figure what do you think I think that's
probably right i mean if you contrast
Matthew and Luke I think you see two
different models of church that we see
attested in our sources by the end of
the first century and by the beginning
of the second century one focused on
individual Lee eros yeah most prominent
of which is Ignatius of
antioch probably from the same place
that Matthew as cosmonium I think it
came from and the other more presbytery
lot'll our collective model and I think
Luke especially with his portrait of a
elders of my leaders exactly yes Aslan
that's right has that understanding of
how the church works so there's a kind
of gala Terry imagining either part of
the concepts right of the puzzle and of
not given a part as much Robin Wright
and it's interesting to watch those two
different models develop and they the
course of one of the toughest things in
teaching church polity to seminarians is
that there is not a new testament
version of our church leadership works
but that in some ways the different
polities of our different churches find
predecessors in different biblical
streams so that that fight about the new
testament church is kind of a lost cause
indeed but in any case Luke is
interested in the church and very much
these disciple things point in that
direction now it's interesting that the
first one of the first things that Luke
tells us after the call of the 70
disciples in Luke 10 is this famous
story of the Good Samaritan perhaps one
of the most beloved and certainly best
known of the parables of Jesus right up
there with the prodigal son and the
parables are really an important part of
Luke's version of Jesus and it probably
would be worth a while to think a little
bit about what we take parables to be
before we get out of this one well let
me just say a word about my own history
on this one I was in seminary too long
ago in the 60s we were still very much
under the influence of a number of
scholars especially CH Dodd and yaki
miura mia's who insisted that each
parable had one main point and the
purpose of exegesis was to figure out
what that point was in gina's ministry
and then once you got that the pair of
we became a kind of illustration of that
I think I think in some ways Luke is the
toughest counterexample to that because
it seems to me that the parables we love
the best like the Good Samaritan like
the prodigal son are multifaceted and
multi meaning and that if Jesus just
wanted to say Oh love your neighbor he
could have just said love your neighbor
but that as Luke tells that he tells a
story that causes us to think about who
we are in relationship to the story how
the story affects our world and may not
with a quick lesson but comes up with
the kind of reshaping of our vision of
the faithful life so parables are rather
like diamonds with lots of fellas much
more like damage with lots of facets and
the good ones are worth selling
everything together I am yeah well let's
turn then to the parable of the Good
Samaritan and say a little bit about it
it's it comes as a response to a
critical dialogue between Jesus and a
seeker right the seeker who's a lawyer
interestingly which I take it to me not
so much an attorney but somebody who
knows the Jewish law will follow the
Torah trying to find out what he needs
to do to eternal to do eternal life to
find eternal life Jesus asks him what he
understands the law to be he says love
God and love your neighbor as yourself
Jesus says nice answer and then the
lawyer says seeking to justify himself
which is very interesting because that
Paul would say doing just the wrong
thing trying to make yourself righteous
it may be simpler than that just trying
to figure out whether he's doing the
right thing asked who is my neighbor and
I want to point out a couple things to
this and keep me from getting into the
preachy mode because I can feel it
coming let me point out a couple things
on this then we'll have a real
conversation about it Oh what is the way
the thing twists around in some ways
jesus never answers that question he
doesn't at the end of the story it's not
who is my neighborhoods which one acted
like a neighbor so it's not don't ask
who your neighbor is you just go be
neighborly and the answer is which what
acted like a neighbor goes back to our
earlier theme the one who showed mercy
the we are called to be neighborly the
second theme and then I want to pull it
a third theme which I was pointed out to
me only yesterday the second theme is
that the neighbors are Samaritan the one
who acts neighborly is a Samaritan and
we have been so used to this story that
I think it's almost impossible to get
the shock value is it is it the
Palestinian gorilla who reaches down to
the Israeli soldier it's this when when
this one the man at the side of the road
looks up and sees it Samaritan that is
the world turned upside down at that
moment because all the usual good guys
have now passed by and and what you see
is this shock the other thing is
something that was pointed out to me by
Jonah Bartlett who is one of your
students in New Testament who said no
relation no relation to me
well actually close relation to me who
said that he was he was getting ready to
preach on this text and he said what
strikes him in thinking about our
current social situation this goes back
to our confusions our concerns about the
Magnificat is how do we now understand
who we are in relationship for this
strong social issue of being beaten
being left by the side of the road and
he says for him part of the problem is
for Christians to think about what we're
supposed to do while the beating has
taken place taking place how do you stop
the beatings one thing to ask how do you
bind up the wounds of society how do you
make the kind of just society where
fewer people get wounded and I don't
know that that's loose question but I
think it's a really good question for us
well illustrates a very interesting
point about parables that if you insert
yourself into the gallery a different
point you get it get a different story
and I think we'll see that again when we
talk about the product absolutely
absolutely but I want to reinforce a
couple of things that you say it one and
that the parable in some ways is a
response to a question yeah and the
response consists of another not an
answer oh but a statement that you're
asking the wrong question exactly ship
the question entirely and I think a lot
of parables do that if they think they
really did sort of challenge basic
presuppositions on the art of listeners
either in this story world of Luke or
yeah we don't like we tend to
domesticate them by getting easy answers
out of them and they're more complicated
and push us right and on the contrast
between the single point in the multiple
elements you know people like Dodd near
Emmaus would say this is an example
story right just telling you to go and
be like what it is that it is the elder
to go and be merciful but it also
challenges your idea of hooking up the
term good with a category absolutely
looks like a contradiction in terms good
demyx of our artists whose republic
terror whatever yes exactly yeah
merciful al-qaeda member yeah we don't
know how to be there not not a natural
connection exactly let me ask one other
thing I had a conversation not too long
ago with someone who was concerned about
the way in which Jewish leaders were
being provided in this paragraph is
there an element of plena core potential
anti-semitism and the way the priests of
the Levi to people I think the whole New
Testament with very rare exceptions can
be easily construe
food to feed anti-judaism and in my role
both as the teacher in a preacher I try
to find ways to not to do that I think I
actually think in this case whether in
Jesus words or Luke words they're not
there as representative Jews there there
is the typical good guys that is good
Pharisee good scribe good Levite those
all makes sense in that world Good
Samaritan terms it turns it around so we
can say good Republican good Democrat
but good al Qaeda that's that rose us up
so I don't think he's doing it at a
Jewish thing yeah I i would agree i tend
to hear that part of the story again
coming out of a Catholic tradition and
thinking of all the anti-clerical Joe
yeah yeah much closer love with those of
that and we can do that in every
denomination bro yes you can do it and I
could be the butt of it in every
denomination it works are very well
indeed so I think this is a really
interesting example of the parables of
Jesus it's a great meant to be heritage
countering some more of them very soon
yeah I'm a great example the other the
one other thing I wanted to hold up
because it's it's again indicative of
what Luke does and maybe what Jesus does
but certainly what does is the variant
so we come out of this story thinking
all right what's Christian faithfulness
Christian faithfulness is showing mercy
getting out doing something in my son's
we'd stop the beating before it happens
then we have this next story very next
story Martha and Mary bartha looks like
the paradigmatic Samaritan type meeting
the needs of the hungry in the kitchen
taking care bartha is that closer to the
Levi to the Pharisee ignoring
everybody's human needs to do prayerful
things and suddenly Jesus says ah Mary's
chosen the better part so just when I
think I've got what the gospel is about
Luke says well sometimes this and
sometimes that and up that I think the
tricky thing one of the many tricky
things about the gospel is we want to
make it principles that always apply and
the problem is it's a call that always
has to be obeyed and sometimes what was
just the right thing to do in case a is
not the right thing to do in case P
which makes the faithful life very
tricky Luke has two hands doesn't it has
two hands on the other always doing it I
always
I want to highlight one other thing in
that Mary and Martha episodes you just
mentioned and that is that the cult
prayer yeah which i think is another
important theme in Luke and we haven't
taught you to be much about it do you
want to say just a little bit of well
very important here very important in
that we see Jesus praying and boot more
than anywhere else very important in the
chapter 11 we have a great deal of
conversation about the way in which
prayer operates we have his version of
the Lord's Prayer and we have the sense
I think that it's the prayerful life
that keeps us in touch with this spirit
which is what drives faithfulness and so
faithfulness apart from Clare runs dry
very fast i think polluted that's right
is interesting that just before jesus
gives us the Sermon on the the plane in
low key stopped praying to go up the
very different from the portrait that we
have in in Matthew and right after the
Mary and Martha episode we have as you
say the law I think I'd love to get your
read on this but I think in loose gospel
more than any other Jesus is the
exemplary Christian in addition to
everything else he does he shows us how
to leave the faithful life and prayers a
big part of that mm-hmm it's interesting
that the wording of the Lord's Prayer in
Luke emphasizes forgiveness of sins yes
I which is a great looking deep yep yep
thank you